foreign
[Music]
we're here to celebrate Selena Gomez
tonight
because of this really thoughtful and
courageous and quite frankly brilliant
documentary film and we're gonna do it
here at the historic Eiffel Tower
Theater downtown Los Angeles
and we're gonna do it with you the fans
oh
foreign
it's a different kind of Applause I
think it feels different I do don't you
know it's because I feel like people
have seen my diary someplace it's almost
supportive it's like we love you
um it's uh it's great to see you um this
is cool what a great location for us to
be able to hang out and thank you guys
for being here this is so great it's
beautiful
um I wanted to start by just simply
asking the most obvious human question
we should always start any conversation
with which is how are you
uh I don't know actually it's been weird
the documentary exists and it's out and
it's been six years in the making and I
have moments where I'm relieved in the
moments where I can't believe it it's
out is it a good thing is it a bad thing
I think I'll always have this internal
struggle of of just figuring out if I'm
doing the right thing and it's been
really validating so far that this is
something good and that means the world
to me so well I know that you haven't
been actively reading the critical
reviews and why would you I mean how do
you read a review of Your Life
strange but the reviews are in right
[Applause]
yeah
yeah and um and rightfully so this film
is is just brilliant and we're gonna
we're gonna get into it but I sort of
made you a promise a week ago when we
spoke that we're trying to have fun yeah
because I think that there's there's
probably a
a desire from people who've seen the
documentary to ask a lot of questions
about what you went through and I can
imagine that's the reason you made the
documentary to not have to answer those
questions over and over again
essentially yeah essentially yeah
um but it does lead me to the question
which is why did you make this
documentary from your perspective
I think originally I thought I was going
to make a traditional tour documentary
about my music and about the Revival
tour and as I recognized my mental state
at that time I look back at that girl
and I don't even recognize her anymore I
it broke my heart to see myself talking
about my body and how it needed to look
a certain way and I felt I just felt
really bad
and I had to cancel that tour that was
the first toy I had to cancel after 55
shows though I mean you really put the
time in already I that's most people
just for the record that's most people's
full World Tour yeah 55 shows we were in
the middle yeah and it was it was really
hard because I I never ever want to let
anyone down and I always want to show up
for for people but I knew that I
couldn't keep going so I had to stop
then I picked it back up again and we
started to film my trip to Kenya and we
thought maybe we could just do a quick
little short on this adventure that
we're going on and this experience then
I had to go straight to London and Paris
and I quickly realized that all of this
stuff that was going on in my life
it all started with me all started with
how am I feeling how am I navigating
through all of these different things
that are going on in my life how am I
surviving and ultimately we realized
that it's going to be a story about my
mental health Journey it's not going to
be necessarily a puff piece it's going
to show every part of me and that's the
good the bad the ugly and the real
you know I think great documentaries
aren't so much reactive I think a lot of
them can be that way they react on
periods of Life try to retell that story
in an entertaining way it's great to
watch but great documentary films are
proactive and when I watch them I feel
like the subject is actually learning
about themselves and going on a journey
of and the documentary is guiding that
process almost more than you are guiding
the documentary did it feel that way
that without the doc you may not have
actually
have pushed forward in the way that you
did I I think so I would like to believe
that Alec and I had a relationship where
even in the weakest moments where I had
a lupus flare up and it was really
painful he even asked me a few times am
I comfortable being recorded and I
thought well I I want to be able to show
people all of it so just go ahead and
that's weird to to say but it also felt
really
it also felt like a big relief because I
know that I'm not the only one that's
hurting that way and it should be talked
about and it should be seen
but what about when you saw it it's one
thing to be living it and experiencing
it you have this trust with the camera
already in life to some degree you
understand its role but then you look
back on that footage edited or otherwise
it's got to be tough for you it's tough
for me it's tough for us
actually seen it all the way through one
time I I can't I don't think I could
watch it again and did you do that so
did you watch that basically almost for
approval like I I can let this go now
yeah I was I was there for the parts of
editing so I could see Transitions and I
knew how the story was going to be told
and then when it was all kind of put
together it was really hard it actually
affected me for a couple of days
afterwards and I realized that that's
just not where I am anymore so I don't
need to revisit it's a beautiful
realization that as well though to
realize you've come so far I know what
you mean when you feel sad when you
recognize somebody who is yourself going
through so much pain it's a it's a
reflection of the work that you've done
since then
but it is kind of bittersweet because
you do feel for that person it's like
you have a relationship with yourself
it's kind of crazy it is a little weird
to be learning and by all means I don't
have life figured out in any way shape
or form I just have a better
relationship with my mind with other
women mental health none of us will
no
that's the point no um but I do
genuinely hope to to start a
relationship with my my mind and my
mental health that I will continue to
grow and I will continue to understand
more and more Alec was the director who
was behind the camera who did you have
to forget that was there there were
actually multiple people we kind of
picked up and and stopped filming
started shooting people were shooting
other things and then so there's
actually a list of names that I would
have to give you that's a huge amount of
trust that you have to put in it's
interesting the age of seven
that is just very unique and I and I
sort of wonder over the course of your
life how you recognize that relationship
with you and a camera something that
captures you well I think it's different
because I I started as an actress first
and I think having a relationship with
the camera and having it be invisible is
just naturally a part of it I love being
on sets I love doing shows and film it's
I kind of thrive in that setting and you
you actually want the camera to to fall
in love with the character you're
creating so I love that then the flip
side is I'm walking out of a hospital
and there's 12 photographers screaming
and wanting a bad angle a bad picture to
you know say I'm not doing well or I'm
in rehab and and then you're just hit
with that kind of
awareness of cameras and that just can
throw you off completely and it
obviously became really unhealthy so
I've had to have different relationships
with how it works even in music videos
it's it's different than being on a set
I probably prefer being on a set of
course that's a big part of why you did
this as well isn't it because of that
false narrative that you've had to exist
with throughout your life this idea that
you live multiple lives is the reality
of who you are in any given moment and
then there's what all of us see based on
what somebody captures and then the
story they choose to tell
I mean that is not reality that's not
your narrative this is this film is was
that a motivation for doing this in
order for people to see it once and for
all a part of it somebody asked me
yesterday they said well do you think
you have now shared so much that people
are going to want more and then I kind
of sat there and I was like what's more
like I think I've said it all I'm like
what else can I say it's probably at
this point in time that's a setup nope
no but I I totally appreciated that
question it's the ending of this movie
is me right here it's me now yeah
um
I want to talk about tools and where it
began and how you've what you've
developed over the course of your life
to to work on yourself and have that
better sense of self-awareness and
self-love it there's an interesting
scene in the film
were you describing terrified of
thunderstorms as a kid
how I'd cope with my diagnosis
what if it happened again
what if the next time I didn't come back
I needed to keep learning about it
I needed to take it day by day
when I was a kid I was terrified of
thunderstorms
I grew up in Texas and I was so scared
that lightning and thunder would mean a
tornado was coming but my mom gave me
these books for kids that explained
storms and lightning and thunder and
basically said The more you learn about
it
the less you're going to be afraid of it
and it really helped
that sort of feels to me like the
beginning of self-help in a way do you
trace it back to then to then yeah I
have one thousand percent would have to
give my mom credit for that I I felt
scared of so many things in life and I
think it's because I grew up anxious I
felt like I needed to perform and I
needed to be the best I possibly could
be and my mom was always that person
that allowed me to be exactly who I
wanted to be and didn't judge me for any
of it and loved me through it and also
would give me the information and the
tools to grow instead of instilling more
fear in me she continued to educate me
on the things that I was terrified of
and she would give me that strength
it's what you do with the strength isn't
it it's how you apply it to your life
and what you absorb that works for you
what works for you you know I I love
yoga I love I like there's certain
things I know that if I don't do it I'm
not good at yoga that's for damn sure
um I think I was good at it but that
definitely works for me it's good for my
mind what works for you it's it's little
things you know I mean I I just had
covid and I was like here it comes I'm
gonna get a little depressed I'm gonna
go down a spiral and I immediately
recognized the little things I needed to
do to get myself out of it so I decided
I needed to change the things I was
watching so I decided to watch things
that were really well written and
beautiful and happy I changed the music
I was listening to I I wanted to listen
to positive things I wanted to feel like
I could be inspired it's something like
taking a walk it's something like
calling a therapist if you have a
sponsor calling a sponsor it's all these
little things that seem so minuscule and
like oh that that won't work that
doesn't matter it actually ultimately
does it's by doing that every day and
even just
getting up and looking at yourself and
being okay with who that person is on
the other side I love that you mentioned
obviously music
um and what's on your positive playlist
oh my God Taylor's new album right now
[Applause]
all of it yeah it's Flawless actually
just that right now actually Flawless no
it is it's a remarkable body of work but
do you also allow yourself to let music
keep you company when you're sad
thousand percent I mean I feel I feel
like that essentially I was raised in a
world where our emotions were
illustrated by music my mom grew up
listening to you know Patsy Cline and
Joni Mitchell and Janice Joplin and then
my dad grew up listening to all the
tahana music that I grew up with like
Selena Quintanilla who I was named after
and he just kind of had a flair for r b
and I was really I was really inundated
with so much
um
so many different styles of music that
it did it was a part of my life I mean I
was 11 years old listening to Coldplay
or Maroon 5 pretending I had been in
love and I was in a breakup in the car
you know I would pretend I'd felt these
emotions that people were talking but
you weren't pretending that's the beauty
of it oh I was for sure like pretend to
cry I mean let me tell you why I think
because because when you feel that so
vividly as a kid and we all feel that
when we love something right we feel it
and then
if you stay feeling that
whenever 10 12 years later you find
yourself doing what with who
singing a song with Chris Martin
yeah I didn't actually put that together
but yes that's you only get there if you
feel it so there's no pretending going
on there that's true um
there's some incredibly poignant moments
when you go home we've seen this in
documentary films before people go home
we all go home it's great but it was
different in this film for me I I really
felt like you were not just going back
to show home and reflect on what it
meant to you you were searching for
purpose there
what was that experience like visiting
the neighbors visiting the friends
there's one scene in particular where
you catch up with someone who went to
school with you and her daughter's there
and it feels so full circle it's crazy
do you know who this is
Selena Gomez
the one that you hear the songs of yeah
[Laughter]
she's my dramatic way wow
come here but
no yeah you're the alpha man yes she's
real mommy went to school with her she
lives right down the street from me
mommy grew up with her
does that make you happy
well thank you I appreciate it it was
good seeing you I'm glad everything is
good with you and yeah went better trust
me it was real scary at that point
because I grew up with you I knew it was
so busy go through that twist part yeah
thank you I do feel better oh we love
y'all okay bye say bye-bye thank you
well every time I go home I usually
drive by my old neighborhood just
because it feels so good it just it kind
of reminds me so every time I'm home I
actually love going to visit people but
that time I went in and invaded people's
personal space and it was wonderful it
was retracing the steps that got me to
where I am whether I was a little [ __ ]
like disrupting the neighbors or I was
with one of my best friends that I grew
up with and watching her have children
now and have a totally different life
and and to think I could have that life
as well was was a moment too that I
thought and I'm nowhere near that and it
doesn't mean it's a bad thing it can be
a good thing as well it was just so
touching at the end
you had given her daughter this moment
and then she gave you this understanding
of like genuine love and concern from
someone who knew long long ago and it
was such a lovely human moment it was
like the trade gone right yeah yeah do
you know what I mean absolutely when she
looked at me and said she was worried
and she was really happy that I was
doing well I remember thinking like
she means that because I know she knows
who I am and doesn't matter that I've
become whatever I'm still Selena you
know throughout this whole thing we see
this kind of strive for a different
purpose
um you found purpose as a young child
and it was successful but success isn't
purpose it's a byproduct of work and
commitment and connection purpose is
something different when during the
making of the documentary AKA your life
did you did you realize that
you were getting somewhere toward a new
purpose in life this idea of going
Beyond Fame and Beyond attention and
reaching for something more substantial
than that
perhaps it's when I was having
breakdowns when I couldn't hide them
when whether the camera was there or not
I couldn't
get my mind out of I couldn't get out of
my own head
and when I realized those moments kept
stopping me from creating you know a
great tour creating a good year creating
a good attitude it was affecting me and
I knew that we were capturing these
moments and then I went to Kenya and I
figured out like wait a minute is this
is this reality is this this is real
this is what people are walking through
it's so much bigger than what we are
worried about sometimes and I think
there were multiple moments there wasn't
just one where I thought this is going
to be bigger than just me yeah I mean it
it begins a really fascinating journey
in life when you realize that you want
to go and alter your purpose and there's
people around you and it could be just
family and friends who don't understand
what that means there's a scene in the
in the documentary where it's a part of
an interview just part of a promo cycle
and to be fair those happen all the time
like 10 interviews a day knock it out
get it done as content but you're ready
to announce this even in a small way
like I want to do something bigger and
it just doesn't land and it's like wow
this is going to be a longer journey I
just looked at your face and I thought
you realize in that moment this is not
just a quote so annoying you're not
gonna get you're not gonna get away with
this with a quote it's gonna have to
require a lot of time exactly this is
where we celebrate Selena for a
different reason
for the work that you've been doing and
and really going out there and walking
the walk you know um the rare impact
fund wondermind these mean something to
you now just like your aunt and your
fans do can you talk about what how
fulfilling it's been working in this
space
um it actually feels wonderful I think
it started honestly when I was 14 and I
had a mom come up to me and she was a
single mom with four kids and you know
they were from Mexico and they actually
were from a town close to mine where my
family's from and she said thank you for
just being who you are because my kids
can look at someone on TV and they look
like you and that is something they can
aspire to be or do and I didn't
understand it because to me I just
thought well I'm I am who I am but when
I recognize the responsibility that I
had been given with my platform I truly
felt like it was bigger than me most of
the time when I would go through dark
moments I would get back up like over
and over and over again because of
people like you it was it was hard for
me to get myself up for me but I knew if
I didn't and I stayed swallowed in in a
pit of pain I would be letting all of
you down and I couldn't live with that I
could not do that and then I had to
learn how to do it for myself
that means I had to let people down and
say okay I can't tour anymore I can't
release music right now I'm physically
just not able to and now I can have a
good balance of being the best version
of myself for me which also means I can
be the best version for other people
yeah exactly and now it's not doing it
for anyone else it's it's helping others
do for themselves
you know that's that's what I'm taking
from the the next chapter of your life
at the end of this film
you know it ends with you going to the
White House it ends with you making a
commitment to this conversation
when we met for the first time
I realize now looking at the timeline of
the documentary that you were really in
it
like you were in it yeah yeah and I
could see that I think I felt that and I
think that's reflected and you can see
it on let's reflect on the kind of
conversation we had but both of us
landed on a subject that we're both
passionate about which is increasing
awareness around mental health and the
need for self-awareness self self help
we're seeing changes and you've been
instrumental in helping make those
changes happen I want to give you a
round of applause for that thank you so
much I appreciate it thank you
so you've started to do the groundwork
how's your experience been there and and
where are we going is it going in the
right direction do you feel like it's
working are we helping I I want to say
yes because I'm going to always be
hopeful I think making those those
moments happen for yourself are really
important I don't mind being the person
that is a voice for mental health
because it's my life and it's a part of
who I am and I want people to start
becoming more and more comfortable with
that conversation and I want it to stop
being this label that terrifies people
or people don't believe in it it's or
think that it's not a real thing if I
were to release this documentary before
the pandemic maybe people would have
thought I was crazy
I had people who watched the documentary
and said had it come out before I don't
think I could have related to certain
things so it was really interesting to
to hear people reacting to this movie
and and actually saying oh I didn't know
I had that but I I did struggle with
that as well what kind of how has it
affected your relationship with your art
as an artist it doesn't come as a
surprise to anyone here that your most
successful song is also probably one of
your most honest yes and I think that
that's a genuine reflection of Truth
being expressed through ART so now that
you are really in a place where you
understand your truth better than ever
and have courage to share it we're
waiting for that album of your career
[Music]
it's
sorry pressure well no you said the bar
not me I'm just acknowledging it no it's
look it's been if I'm being completely
honest which I have been it's
um it's been really difficult I'm really
used to going into a setting with the
same people in my circle and just
banging out music
to be honest I'm now telling stories
that people don't know
people I've dated that people don't know
people experiences I've had that people
don't know I created this whole private
life that was just mine and I feel like
now I have to tell these stories and
people are gonna ask a lot of questions
I just put it in perspective otherwise
we're never getting another album
so let me try and save this
can I say you didn't have a choice
before I don't think I think that
everyone decided this was who you were
in you the stories you had to tell
correct
every artist on the planet gets to
decide how they talk about their
relationships and their emotions and
their feelings that remain private until
the moment they express them you've just
now caught up to every other artist on
the planet
thank God I feel accomplished do you
know what I mean when I say that you can
do it your way now exactly I feel like
I've earned it and I just don't want to
release anything that's not perfect and
it's getting there that's all I can say
it's getting there awesome we have fan
questions
yes my favorite by the way my favorite
my favorite elephants but no seriously
my favorite like if I could spend the
next half of my life just asking fan
questions
oh here we go
um
how does it feel I'm gonna emphasize
that word how does it feel to be your
true and vulnerable self in front of the
camera
um
I like I can relax now I feel like now
you guys know everything that
I was walking through and you didn't
judge me and you were there for me
constantly and it just made me feel
normal and I really appreciate that
what scene in my mind and me are you
most proud of
it was probably when I was rehearsing
for the amas I wasn't ready and I
started to listen to a Lauren Daigle
song and
I felt like
that was me really trying to push
through something that was difficult and
ultimately it wasn't my best performance
but that moment I had rehearsing meant
more to me anyway because it was me
trying to heal it wasn't like I wrote
the song and I was like I'm over it it's
like no I actually am still kind of
feeling it so it's terrifying to get up
and sing crazy you promoted it I mean it
was such a personal release it really
was but it was such a gift at the end of
all of it yeah and by the way go and
look at any other documentary film do
you know how many times you'll see a
singer who can sing as well as Selena
can leave a scene in there where she
misses a note it doesn't happen they hit
the editing floor really quick so it was
it was great to see you do that and just
leave it all on the on the table what
was the hardest scene for you to put in
the hardest state was probably the tour
content in the beginning
it was really honest
it was just because I had been so
inundated with
comments about my body I mean there's
there's a reason why I was talking about
myself that way I I don't just make that
up I had been told I needed to look
better that I needed to dress cooler
that my tour was kind of lame and I was
trying to be someone I wasn't
that was happening all the time to me
and I think that's abusive
and I realized that watching that back
I'm never gonna let anyone
ever again make me feel that way
and I gained my strength back when I
realized
actually no
that girl wasn't lame that girl didn't
need a better body that girl didn't need
to look like this I was meant to be
exactly who I am and once I was released
from a voice that was in my life
I didn't fall
I actually rose up
and that's the best thing
thank you
[Applause]
I know there was a longer edit yeah
there was a longer added for sure that's
not even that's not even Insider talk
every film has a longer edit
um
was there anything that you really wish
looking back on it now that you had been
able to get in there or
you wanted to get in there or that maybe
you may show another time or just a
scene that you really wish had gone in
the dark probably more content with my
fans I think because the pandemic
happened I canceled my tour the meet and
greets were my only connection to people
me being here is such a high because
I've missed this more than anything I've
missed connecting like I can't wait to
meet all of you and hug you and yeah I
was gonna ask not to put two not to make
you find a point of it but is this sort
of the first time in a long time you've
had this experience basically
so I'm so happy it feels so good how
does it feel to know you're changing our
lives and I love that somebody wrote
that question and included everybody
and making us feel seen when it comes to
mental health and this question ends
with I love you
well I love you I love all of you
um I
I guess wait what was the question
oh yes no oh my gosh if I am able to
help one person with this I am on Cloud
Nine forever I mean I think you know
people ask me what would I like to be
remembered by and of course I love what
I do so the projects and things that I'm
a part of I'm really proud of
but I hope that I'm remembered by my
heart and I'm remembered by
simply wanting to see people for who
they are and love them authentically
truly and as
purely as I possibly can
in our final moment today here in this
beautiful Apple Tower Theater downtown
Los Angeles I wanted to honor the fact
that you're getting to see your fans
face to face in the same room for the
first time in a very long time
we all came out of a really crazy few
years where this just wouldn't have been
possible and what you've been going
through personally made it extra
especially further away
so I just wanted to give you a chance to
just talk to your fans directly and just
say something to them while they're here
and we can end like that okay well
here's my thing a minute talking all of
your ear off when I meet you because I
like that
but truly I think
me releasing this was one of the most
terrifying things I've done but I am so
grateful that people like you are able
to watch it and hopefully even if it's a
friend that you know is walking through
something that you're able to be a voice
for them
I can't do any of this without you guys
I know that's such a cliche and maybe
you hear it from other people as well
but at the end of the day it's just me
my core friends and us and I believe
that we're in this together and I just
want to continue to be the best version
of myself that I can and to love you
guys fully and truly for who you are
because you do that for me so thank you
so much
[Applause]
watch the film now with your Apple TV
Plus subscription on whatever device you
stream on your Apple TV MacBook Smart
TVs game consoles PlayStation and Xbox
connected devices Roku or Amazon Fire
just look for the Apple TV app if you
don't have a go to the App Store on your
device and download it
excuse me
[Music]